The machines are here.
Are we going to lose our jobs?
Will we ever have any
privacy ever again?
Fiction has long predicted a
radically different world with AI.
And mostly, they're dystopias.
AI's impact used to be
the realm of sci fi.
But then Chat GPT happened
and everything changed.
Chat GPT is being
heralded as a game changer...
Chat GPT, the artificial intelligence..
Chat GPT...
...is this week's sensation
...is said to be the creator of Chat GPT...
We're waking up to the threats
from AI pretty quickly.
It's not just the jobs under threat,
the hyper-charged discrimination.
Teachers are sounding the alarm
about the threat to education.
Machine-produced art threatens
to completely alienate us from one another.
AI may even pose an
existential threat to mankind.
It's clear that we have to regulate AI.
But how?
What should we ban?
And how can we unleash its
benefits in medicine and industry?
In this episode of What's Left?,
we're going to dive into what we can do
to make sure that AI helps people
rather than harms us.
Let's give it a go.
What?
Headlines, on AI currently focus on dystopian
concerns about existential threats on AI.
Hypothetical ideas
about it turning on us.
But AI is already hurting people.
Already we see that AI reflects society's
prejudices and structural inequalities.
We've seen AI be racist, be homophobic.
We've seen police use AI to predict crime,
curtailing basic freedoms
we had taken for granted.
So what do progressives do about it?
The EU has to regulate.
I spoke to Alex Saliba, vice-president for Digital,
about what we've done so far.
We also took to the streets
to ask people what they think.
They have to be careful that they
don't overdo it and it stays safe.
You know the film AI?
I just don't want
that to happen.
It may be useful, but limited.
We need to see it from a distance.
and for the moment we can't.
When Chat GPT revolutionised
the way that we look at AI,
when we started seeing the threats
that AI can pose to our democracies,
to our privacy, to transparency,
to what is going on online,
people were becoming much
more aware of the need
to have a piece of legislation
which basically protects the rights.
The large language models,
foundation models, generative AI,
were not part of this regulation initially.
So we had to modify this legislation
to adapt to these challenges,
to have transparency rules
on deepfakes, on the generation of content
that needs to be recognised as non-human made.
And also to protect
copyright and authors
so that they are not depredated by
the training of an AI system
without their rights being respected.
And we innovated the text
with this because we think
that this new direction of
AI needs to be regulated
as much as we did for the
more traditional AI systems.
If you would ask me what changes did you see
in the discourse a year ago and today?
I would say that people are much
more aware of the need to regulate
not only AI, but all digital technologies.
First of all, protecting users,
protecting our consumer rights.
Secondly, protecting privacy rights
and all the fundamental freedoms.
Today we have two worlds:
The offline world and the online ecosystem,
and we are interacting heavily
in this online ecosystem.
Therefore, we cannot have two
sets of fundamental rights.
We, S&D, tried to ban as much
as possible all those techniques
and the systems that might threaten
the fundamental rights of people.
Because facial recognition, for instance,
on publicly accessible spaces
means that you can be targeted,
you can be identified in any moment.
So it affects your privacy life.
You will consider twice before
going to a protest, for instance,
because the next day you might lose your job.
The problem is going to be controlling it
because it's very easy
to use it dishonestly and...
then particularly with mass data and...
but that's no different from the Internet and
they've had a problem controlling that as well.
But it's been of great benefit.
AI will be too.
AI is scary.
We cannot just rely on these
Silicon Valley bros to protect us.
That's why the EU is doing something.
Some things we just have to ban.
We don't want remote biometric
identification in real time,
and in most cases also in non-real time.
It means the cameras,
to have surveillance on public spaces.
Imagine demonstrations or imagine a protest,
If you are a civil servant and you protest against
the government, you are not going to do it
If you know that you can be detected,
you can be identified in any certain moments.
This is always this battle
between freedom and security.
We don't want emotion recognition
in the workplace and in school.
We don't want predictive policing.
It's just not fair that we violate
the presumption of innocence.
And we have seen that these
systems are simply not working.
And in the end, they discriminate people,
especially from certain ethnic backgrounds.
We think we need to be very careful about
all these issues of social control to AI.
With important elections coming up
in the USA and the EU,
democracy itself is under threat by AI.
Democracy is a fragile good.
It needs to be defended by any
risk of manipulation and control,
and we need to preserve
the freedoms of our people.
Could you imagine, even in Europe,
in some places,
how certain authorities could use these systems
to create social control against opposition,
against people that are not liked, against minorities?
So we need to be very, very careful.
That was a lot.
But it's not all bad news.
AI has the power to change
a lot of things for the better.
The impact on medicine, on industry,
is potentially mindblowing.
AI is also creating a lot of opportunities,
new job opportunities,
New opportunities when it comes
to education, when it comes to research,
When it comes to the transportation sector.
Therefore, the opportunities are there.
What we want to do is continue to enhance
those opportunities by creating a safe ecosystem.
We should also have more AI literacy.
It is useless to have AI and people
not able to use it and enhance its potential.
People will have to learn, even though
it's artificial intelligence and robots
we will have to drive the robots initially,
so people will have to learn artificial intelligence
and that will lead to more
artificial intelligence jobs in the market.
AI for sure will be able to change our lives
for the better if we manage to regulate it correctly.
It's really a big power.
It can really change the way we work, the way
we do things in a way that can reduce burdens,
can increase our abilities,
can make our time better spent.
These advantages, which in general
we can say are linked to reducing time loss
and also increasing productivity and maybe
give us more free time and have a better life.
This is the EU AI Act and we packed it
full of progressive stuff.
One of everyone's biggest concerns
is losing their job to AI.
Or we are worried about our jobs becoming worse,
more precarious, as we learn to fear our AI managers.
But we've made sure that in the EU, companies
will have to consult with trade unions
when introducing AI  to the workplace.
I think that we should definitely think about
what our economies are actually made up
in terms of the labour force and
see what we want to protect.
So I think it's a really good time for us
to think about what we want as societies.
We added in this regulation a reference
to the need for social dialogue
in view of an agreement to allow us to put
into force an AI system inside the workplace.
We want this to be part
of the social dialogue.
Ultimately, if you open
a small window, especially
if you open a small window for big tech companies,
for companies who are thriving on our data,
who are monetising our personal data,
then you will have total chaos out there.
Therefore, for us, this is always a priority for
safeguarding user rights,
for safeguarding our privacy,
for safeguarding fundamental rights online
in each and every piece of
legislation that we are negotiating,
that we are moving forward
here in the European Parliament.
The S&D put the person in the centre of this
piece of legislation, while the EPP of course,
they're supporting business, so
business as usual. And for me, sometimes,
they really do not care that much
about the fundamental rights.
The Socialists and Democrats Group is working to
make sure that AI is for the many and not for the few.
That it is creating
opportunities for everyone,
that it is creating a better life, a happier life
for everyone and making a better society.
AI is here.
The digital transformation is upon us.
And it's up to us to build
the world we want.
To use AI to give power to the people
and not to curtail our freedoms.
AI should liberate people at work and
not make employment more precarious.
The EU is regulating
with the EU AI Act,
and we're making sure that Socialists and Democrats
are leading the way in writing this.
And if AI does end up winning,
then personally I love AI.